So next round after that we have to
take a break for food
Game started Fire breather
so
Spanish Let's
see if we can get the main variant
So I'll play the
ancient chicorin variant
which is also in the most ancient form
yes the C5 the old Fischer train
where I am too  I don't really know how
best to position myself against that.
I'll try it with
normal development moves. E3
D5 is always a bit of an idea here that
he would like to
get rid of the knight so that he has one more piece
on the 5, but I'll try  whether
I can swap the bishops for each other,
not implausible knight the five
is unpleasant
yes that's what I do with the eight
maybe
it hangs twice if he takes the
position with the knight a bit passively
well don't think about it forever
yes that was to be feared  This is a very
unpleasant position, I can
do very little and he will now
come in there with his pieces. Yes,
move the knight G6 out of it.
I wanted to move the knight F6,
of course not so nice for the pawn position,
but I
would swap the queens  helpful
rook the one, also a normal
reinforcement move, so I wanted to use it to move B6
A4 yes, of course it's also
somehow according to the program,
so we have six
when he exchanges, the knight
then covers eight, but where I'm
not exactly comfortable with the position,
I have to use the variant
obviously look at it again
yes it's not exactly difficult for him to
play but he doesn't do it
badly either well the knight on A8 has
no field
now the rook A1 could play A7 for example
okay he cracks it straight away yes it's also
plausibly good
So
how does the knight come back into play,
not the five you take, the bishop the five
is of course all good of course everything is
good for him
Knight G5 is also an unpleasant
move, well
good but it's not entirely clear now
how he'll progress or
I think pregnant G5  from
tumor one A7 I still do B8
of course passive but
yes small rolls are baked
you can't do more here
yes I thought so I F6
LED knight E7 in weakness of course
the white fields for me
under certain circumstances now H5 knight H4 for
him  could be unpleasant
I could also go F4
but knight easy more possible
maybe also to throw out Sprenger C6 with the
rook Wait a minute what if
he takes and draws you bishop five then
I have set a figure
okay
yes nice is different
okay knight G6 F4 yes  Just
pick them up,
yes of course he can, I
really have to get the knight
moving somehow,
my God, terrible position, what
have I done there? Yes,
he has to get away from the seventh row first,
the only hope is that I
might
end up
with an active one here  King will remain if
he now exchanges correctly, well
that's still okay
yes it's still
much better and much better
I'm 6 G7 anyway as good as gone
F3 is of course correct yes knight E6
is a very unpleasant move that I  I ca
n't use it at all,
yes, there's counterplay somewhere here.
I might try
a position like that Check time warning
F5, so I can take it there.
Maybe I can use it to
go with the knight
more material
completely pointless
check
so well yes it's just broken
and also child's play
C4 is probably not
somehow it's not that good
everything
yes runner e6008 probably just
keep up the pace
that's probably bad
yes you should know  what you play